each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so motion will be done about simple
problems since I databases so we're
going to focus situation for stss which
is the database system I'll be talking
about how we implemented provenance for
it and what we learned from it so I was
going to start with them why lots of
science data is going into databases but
I think we've heard enough for that so
with scientific data it's not enough to
just return the data sometimes when
you're providing such data it's also
important that um people can get that
data later through the same process and
that they can I've very sure that they
can get the data at a later date right
so the data itself is not enough we need
to ensure that it can still be retrieved
even if some of the sources have changed
we need to provide provenance for
results so in this talk for someone
described our database environment and
some of the properties in this
environment and make the provenance
problem interesting the next part is how
we implement a provenance for this
environment and the last parts about
what we learn from it so our database
environment hosts mostly data from a
product called the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey or sdss and it's an astronomy
survey that intends to map over a
quarter of the sky in great detail so so
far we have about 40 terabytes of
database data as far as provenance goes
it's not so much the type of data the
dustiest s provides but it's
said the way the data is released so um
sdss releases data really and frequently
about once a year when it does release
data it doesn't change any existing data
sets it um releases the new data as a
brand new set of data that contains all
the old data and then your data to this
means that SDSS databases are reliably
read-only catalog contents never change
instead you just get new catalogs so in
a read-only database provenance are
usually pretty easy since the contents
of the catalog never change if you want
to recreate a data set you got all you
have to do is rerun the original query
in our environment though we have a few
extra factors that make this problem
more interesting one of these is cast
jobs which is the interface that we
provide web access through so there are
some features and cash straps that are
useful but I'm the one that's important
to provenance is my TB which is
server-side storage for users this means
that every user gets their own database
on the server and they can fill this
with whatever they want this could be
the results from queries on the
read-only database or it can be their
own data that they upload it directly to
us so this means that objects in my TB
can be the results of one or many
queries and it could be dependent on
lots of different objects so the
provenance problem is determining which
objects is our next
so that's the kind of problem our
provenance system is trying to solve so
this system is a really lightweight
provenance system it only depends on
queries and the time they were submitted
and the user that submitted on basic
query log stuff it progresses in three
stages the first stage is to take all
the queries and preprocessing the second
is to generate object dependency graphs
and the third is to generate the result
right so skipping to the end the results
of this process is the simplest part of
the whole process so in a database if
you exclude things that aren't logged
like bulk uploads and that kind of stuff
then every object that's in the database
was created through one or more sequel
queries so the goal this problem on
system is just to return the sequence of
queries that recreates an object great
ok
so the pre-processing step of this
process is first process all the queries
and still them down to just the data
we're going to need for provenance so
sequels fairly complex with a bunch of
different constructs and all that kind
of stuff but for the purpose of
provenance we don't really care about
most of them all we're looking for in
this thing is to find unique objects in
a query and we need to find their usage
so three object types are tables
functions and stored procedures each of
these three types have four different
usage cases so they might be created in
a query they could be changed in the
worry through like an an update or and
insert or they could be destroyed in the
grave if an object in the query but it
doesn't fall into any of those cases
then you can consider it a dependency
because um the query doesn't actually
change the object but the query can't be
wrong without it so the first step in
the pre-processing process is to UM take
a requiring and convert it into a set of
tuples where each tuple represents the
information we're looking for the tuple
is just the name of the object and some
tag that encompasses the type of the
object it is and how it was used so as
an example in this query we can see it's
selecting into a table called my table
so it creates this table so it gets a
tag called see tab that's appropriate
you can't run this query without photo
primary or neighbors so these tags these
tables need to be tagged too and they
get a different type in the gating
dependency and as far as tagging goes
this is it this is all we need to know
about this query to generate or to
relate this query to a provenance later
as far as building provenance goes once
we've tagged every query we don't need
the query anymore we just look at the
tags we only need the query at the last
step when we actually want to recreate
an object we have a provenance for
so most of the query is ignored things
like joins and columns and conditions
these are important to the query but not
to determine whether the query is
related to the provenance of an object
the idea is once we build the sequence
of queries that we're after and actually
run them if we get all the queries in
the right order these kind of details
should resolve themselves on their own
so that was one query we need to do this
for a whole bunch of ways and once we
have all the queries tagged we can take
those tags and store them in a database
and a table actually and then index the
table so with this index table we can
figure out or we can determine the
answer to any question we might need to
ask during provenance construction so
what those questions are is the next
part so the second stage of this
provenance is dependency graph
generation so to determine the
provenance of a given object the first
step we take is we find the most recent
query that altered that object so when
the slide is showing them the first step
from my table we find we search the tag
database and see that the most recent
query that changed his table is called
query one once we find the query we look
up all the other dependencies in that
query in this case there's my other
table and photo primary and then we do
the same thing for those objects so for
those object we look up the queries that
most recently change those and then we
follow the dependency of those so we can
keep doing this until we don't find any
more queries once we do this all the
queries run in dependency order should
be the provenance of the object
right so the primary output how this
process is a list of queries but we also
provide a kind of graphical
representation of the provenance that's
what's shown it's more or less the same
as the paint pro sides on the previous
ones but um it's a little bit different
than it's optimized for showing larger
provenances for instance they take out
the queries the queries are moved so in
this arrangement you have queries a new
of objects and objects is just some
object with the same name it's not
necessarily the same data objects are on
the Left queries are on the top every
cell represents a unique version of an
object so it could mean that the data
has changed in the object and the lines
indicate dependencies
when in this kind of rendering this is
showing the provenance for the object my
table 1 so the highlighted column is
just the most recent query that created
that object one of the dependencies of
that query was pure you one and that
query is shown here and you can follow
this all the way back to the unknowns
stuff so not all objects have full
sequel logs which is okay in our
particular environment so the kind of
objects that don't have a logs are
usually objects that we're on like bulk
uploaded or just on logged but we have
pretty good logs so if we don't have
object or we don't have queries for this
object but we know that they haven't
changed then they don't pose a problem
for recreating the provenance all we
have to do is ensure that those objects
are still there and things should run
okay it can be a little problematic with
user uploaded tables so if i use heard
upload a table and my TB and um dropped
it later then he wouldn't be able to
generate a provenance for that object
for any objects dependent on that object
in the future but um this is a problem
in this plan because this plan was
generated retro actively but in the
future you could do checks on queries
and if the user tried to drop something
that would break any other future
provenances you could at least warn them
right so that was a really simple plan
this is a really big one there are
hundreds of thousands of queries
hopefully in this bigger plan you can
see why the weird rendering makes sense
it's easier to track objects in this you
can just look at say row and you can see
all the versions of the objects and you
can see all the objects in the query
it's still really hard to read but it's
a little clearer so when you get a plan
of this size you might ask a question or
two some of the questions we asked or
how many objects do we have with this
kind of complicated provenance bhai
them how many users are doing this kind
of thing is this a normal thing or more
anomalous thing if you're trying to
answer these questions with just a query
log this is kind of a hard question to
answer but we have a nice tag database
and the provenance for every object so
using those we can try to answer that
kind of question oh you one thing to
look at is just the tag distribution for
all of the queer ISA really covered I
didn't even talk about the Clarissa so
we run this on all the queries and cash
jobs which is since 2003 I think and I
think it's about 500,000 queries it's a
lot of queries and at the time I think
it was from two thousand registered
users these are all of the tags for all
of those queries the tags are named at
the bottom there usually tab is table SP
is stored procedure and anyone the most
common tag it's also a logarithmic scale
so small differences are really big the
most common one is the tab dependency oh
and light columns are objects at rmit be
and dark Hamza columns that are or
objects that are the most common tag is
tab dependency for tables that aren't in
my TB which makes sense given that
people are coming to the site to query
our data other things you can see is the
tables are dropped almost as frequently
as they created it's hard to tell
exactly what that means it could mean
that users are really tidy they're
always cleaning up tables they create
but it seems a good guess that they're
my TV size is too small so they have a
finite size of data to work with and
this indicates that they're continually
have to free up space maybe you can also
see errors in this distribution so
technically since we host mostly
read-only catalogues plus my DB people
shouldn't be able to create objects in
my TB but you can see from the tags
have been quite a few cases where people
have given what the tags are only based
on queries that succeeded we don't tag
failed queries it's a bad sign initially
if thought this was a parsing error but
apparently it's not apparently at some
point sdss had a configuration error on
the server and people could write tune
on my TB context and you can see that on
the chart so the rest of this is
focusing on my TB providing users with
server-side storage is kind of a gamble
you don't know if they're really going
to use it you don't know how well
they're going to use it it could help
them in their work or it could just get
in their way so since we have provenance
for every object we can kind of exploit
that and try and figure out if they're
actually using it well and so the next
three sides will be talking we'll be
trying to profile users will be trying
to see on how many users actually use my
TB in the way that we intended which was
as a workbench and how many are just
kind of it's getting in the way for him
right so we intend originally intended
my TB to be a work bench this means that
it's not just a place to dump your
results and get them later it should be
a place where you're continually re
referencing objects that you've created
before right that's a little bit tough
to measure so we have a couple of
metrics work the first one is the
maximum object versions one way that
would tell you with pretty good
confidence that the user is using my TB
in a workbench fashion as if they have
an object in there my TB or they used to
have an object and their mighty be that
um has more than one version this means
that they have updated an object and
their mighty be at least once so this
chart is classifying users by their one
object with the most versions so
unfortunately this doesn't look very
good twenty percent of users have only
twenty percent of users have revised
data in a mighty be table more than once
given the the first version the create
counts as a version that's bad six
percent of users have never even used my
to be at all that indicates the users
don't really use object versions that
often but that doesn't necessarily
indicate that they're not using my TB as
a workbench for example in sequel it's
syntactically a lot easier to use
objects as dependencies in new objects
rather than updating old objects so this
metric is designed to look for that
right so instead of looking for object
versions in this one we're looking for
the number of other dependencies on
other objects they've created within the
same query and we classify each user by
the object they have with the most
complex provenance counting those
objects does that make any sense okay
right so it is if the users used my TB
as a workbench at some point they should
have at least one object in there in
their history that's dependent on
another object and mighty me that would
indicate that they've at least taken a
two step process to the thing so using
this metric the results are a little bit
better thirty-eight percent have used a
mighty be object
twice I remotely at once anyway but it's
still not very good that's still less
than half the users um it would be nice
if both of these metrics we're talking
about different sets of users but
unfortunately they're not so every user
that's ever created an object version in
this data set has also to created a
maximum or a dependency query so thirty
percent is the top or thirty eight
percent so it would seem that only
thirty point thirty-eight percent of our
users are using my TB in the fashion
that we intended them to be using it
according to this metric we use a
counter and everything so the next thing
and the last thing that we're looking at
here is um query contribution since
every user the past version was also in
depth we can ignore depth so we're just
going to looking we can ignore version
so we're just looking at user
dependencies here this time instead of
counting the users we're also
correlating them with the number of
queries that have come from those users
in a given category so the chart on the
left is the same one from here that's
classifying users the chart on the right
is color-coordinated to be the same sets
of users but this time it's looking at
how many queries they've run so when you
look at it this way it looks pretty good
so as far as users that have passed the
tests that have used my TB in an
approved fashion they own it's almost
seventy seven percent the queries have
come from those users this doesn't mean
that everyone is using mighty be great
this is also not the most definitive
metric because in order to make a
multi-step object it just requires more
queries but it seems like a good sign it
seems like a pretty safe indication that
at least a healthy portion their users
have adopted the workbench pattern
so this is our lightweight provenance
implementation it's not the most robust
implementation in the world but the
positives are it requires next to no
storage overhead all you need is a tag
database and the tags take up less room
than the query logs everything it needs
is in the query log so you don't need to
have an active database to run this you
can generate provenance for objects that
don't exist anymore or you can generate
the list of queries for even when you
don't have the database you can't
recreate them but at least you can still
see your work it's pretty simple to
implement all the downsides tend to
revolve around it actually having to
rerun all of the work it doesn't cash
anything so in order to recreate an
object you have to do all of the work
that you did again and it can be slow to
recreate objects but for a certain type
of data environment that's mostly a the
host primarily non-volatile data and has
extensive quality or query logs than the
seems at least for us like a pretty good
way to do provenance hold on